trtrois jours, c'est la réalité
dedes résidents de Shanghai.
IlIls se remettent à peine d'un
coconfinement strict de deux mo,
ququi s'est terminé à la mi-mai.
CeCe résident croit qu'un seul
tetest par semaine serait
susuffisant.
LaLa Chine maintient sa politiqe
COCOVID zéro. Mais changement
imimportant : la quarantaine por
leles cas de contact rapproché
aiainsi que les voyageurs arrivt
dede l'étranger est réduite
dede moitié.
ElElle sera désormais de
sesept jours dans un centre
gogouvernemental, suivis
dede trois jours à la maison.
LeLes tests fréquents et autres
rerestrictions semblent être
llà pour rester, cependant.
LaLa politique COVID zéro chinoe
ririsque d'être appliquée pour
leles cinq prochaines années.
JuJusqu'à ce printemps, Taïwan
auaussi était ancrée dans
unune politique de COVID zéro.
CoConfinement des résidents,
memesures de distanciation
sosociale, ces mesesures ont été
asassouplies au moment où les
coconfinements chaotiques en Che
dédéfrayaient les manchettes.
TaTaïwan a accepté de subir
unune nouvelle vague de cas
afafin de marquer son approche
didifférente de celle de la Chi.
" "La Chine priorise davantagee
cocontrôle de la pandémie que ls
drdroits de ses citoyens, affire
lele ministre de la Santé de
TaTaïwan. Pas nous", ajoute-t-i.
C Cet expert, lui, croit que
TaTaïwan n'avait pas le choix
d'd'adapter sa stratégie à ce qi
sese fait ailleurs dans le mond.
LeLe chauffeur de taxi Chen Yu-i
s's'estime chanceux de ne pas
susubir les restrictions
sasanitaires chinoises.
IlIl constate cependant que
seses clients lui parlent
enencore de la pandémie...
etet qu'ils ont auaussi peur
ququ'avant. Une nouvelle vague
dede cas balaie l'île depuis
l'l'assouplissement des mesures
enen avril.
DaDans ce marché public de Taip,
leles allées demeurent moins
acachalandées qu'à l'habitude.
CeCette employée a perdu la moié
dede son chiffre d'affaires.
ElElle espère revoir sa clientè.
LeLe retour à une vie plus norme
dedemeure timide à Taïwan
etet les touristes ne peuvent ps
y y contribuer.
LeLes frontières demeurent
fefermées pour l'instant.
I Ici Philippe Leblanc,
R Radio-Canada, Taipe